a lot of good to see you know how
worried are you by this drop well it
stagnation if we hadn't got some great
companies that were actually booking the
trend and I think we would be very
worried I think that this is a wake up
call
we know that when government and
industry focus on a target they achieve
it and that's why we do this annual
report this annual report by the
pipeline is the only count that exists
and the most comprehensive count of the
numbers of women on UK 4350 executive
committee's their roles and their value
and this is only the second year that
we've done it and it's proved it's worth
in terms of doing it because most people
thought because of the noise you know
policy that therefore we would be
achieving things and well onto target
and it's shown that actually we've taken
the eye off the ball why do you think
it's happening I mean is it just under
the eye being taken off the board people
being obsessed by things like brexit and
the election and all I think that we
didn't realize how much focus it took to
move the dial on on executive directors
now most of us would agree that the
executive piece who runs our companies
is the most important if you look at the
consistent evidence from IMF McKinsey
and our report two years running there
is a bottom-line benefit and they're
this low growth economy you cannot rule
out the game that having a better
balance on your executive committee
brings your organization why does this
happen there why are there these
problems is it just that women I mean
quite often it's said to get onto an
executive committee you've got to have
finance skills that's got to be a
prerequisite and all the women will have
necessarily worked in finance you're in
the business is that a factor no it's
the profit and loss issue that is the
key so if you do a study of how many
chief Ekta or the background of chief
executives they've had profit and loss
experienced in their career getting to
the executive corridor and that means
that they then know how to make money
for the business and so it is really
worrying that stubbornly the numbers of
women that have profit and loss roles on
the executive piece is so stubbornly
small and the number of women therefore
that are executive directors on PLC
boards is
only 8% so the most senior positions in
the British British business 92% of them
are men
I mean you train up a lot of these women
I mean there's no a shortage of good
quality people out there so boards are
not being thoughtful enough in terms of
although this is a count so this is an
account and people can get it on a exec
pipeline comm they can get all the
evidence and also our conclusions well
if you take three of our clients so you
take tens that's private equity they've
just announced their third woman object
yet turns water their third woman on
their executive committee two of which
have been through our programs and
they've had a steadfast program over the
last five years to address this Aeon
they've got three women on their UK
Executive Committee two of which have
been on our programs and they have a
steadfast policy to address it and then
you take chemin s a newer client for
ours but actually they are putting women
through our programs and they've got
three women on their executive committee
so it takes focus and where you focus
you can achieve the outcome so what
about quotas then I mean Davis
considered this when he was looking at
non execs on boards I mean it is
something that board should be compelled
to do defunct I think that we do I think
that the targets so we met our target
when it came to non-executive directors
when the government through Vince Cable
and Mervyn Davis worked together and
focused on it I think having a split
focus doesn't work it's the executive
piece that is most important it's where
we're seeing slippage and it's where
chief executives need to target right at
the top they need to be promoting their
most talented women to the executive
committee because that stops the flight
from the most talented people further
down the pipeline and then that means
that they got further to they've got
more women to work with because most
corporations are really good at
recruiting women and the most talented
of graduates what they're not good at is
promoting them to the enth level which
is on the executive committee I'm
slightly confused here so are you saying
your back quotas or not no I'm staying
up at targets your back targets not
quotas how bad would it have to change
them for they all get for you not I
don't think we need to go there because
we're in many
boardrooms and actually people are
talking about this what they are now
seeing with our figures is they need to
do more than talk they need to actually
do concerted action and actually quite a
lot of the companies we're working with
are getting there let's hope this is
enough of a wake-up call
all right wanna fit Simon's from the
pipeline thanks for joining me thank you